breakfast no it does not
omelets are a vehicle for I mean
it's a pallet you put anything you want
in there omelets suck no they don't
omelets suck you suck um because
breakfast is a bullshit-ass meal no that
anybody can throw together at any time
of day and it doesn't take any thought
or effort let's let's be honest even
though I like them let's be honest when
you think of lunch you think of one
thing I think over everything else
you're nothing without a sandwich
nothing yeah dinner is the man spreading
of meals it flops down its legs are wide
on anybody are you are you wild bro
dinner is a family institution it's the
threaded fabric of our society as people
people come to break bread that's dinner
when I was a kid my mom once in a while
ago how about we do breakfast for dinner
tonight in my head I was saying you lazy
son of a you're gonna put into it